first doses of the covet 19 vaccine were
once again being administered today
right here in clark county this comes
after a major winter storm caused
significant delays in shipments
around the country joe muller joins us
live at the las vegas convention center
with more joe yeah both cashman center
and the las vegas convention center uh
here we're back in full swing today
after that delay in shipments people
here are now wrapping up after getting
their
second dose now according to southern
nevada health district officials around
10 percent of the population in
clark county have received at least one
dose right now those 65 and older are
eligible to get their shot during
today's weekly copen 19 vaccine update
clark county officials said
they received the delayed shipment
yesterday and are receiving this week's
most likely tomorrow so they are now
playing ketchup
first doses were put on hold and some
second doses were canceled due to that
storm
now this week the health district
launched a new platform on the website
to set up appointments the feedback so
far
has been good when you get cancelled and
rebooked
we weren't sure if we were supposed to
call them if we were supposed to go
online
but the actual process of booking online
was fairly easy i would say
now the health district says they are
also looking at ways to expand
availability with a rtc bus
transportation route two vaccine
locations and possibly
opening up a third mega site like the
one we have here at the convention
center now some people are still worried
about getting their second dose on time
on that date that they're given from
their first one
they say they did have walk-ins
available today at the cashman location
so if you are one of those people who
has that concern the best thing to do
is to call to get an appointment the
same day reporting live at the
convention center joe mohler 8 news now